[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدي العربيه واهلا بكم الى
التاسعه مع ليلى الاختيار استهلها بابرز
العرب
قذائف اليورانيوم البريطانيه تعيد مخاوفا
اندلاع صراعا نووي انطلاقا من اوكرانيا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه يدعو دول العالم
لاعتقال بوتين وتقديمه للمحاكمه اذا زار
دوله
شبح الخروج من افغانستان يعود للواجهه
بريطانيا تحقق مع جيشها وامريكا تراجع
اسباب الانسحاب
بكامل طاقته للسعابيه الحرم المكيه
استعدوا لاستقبال اكثر من خمسه ملايين
معتمر خلال شهر رمضان الكريم
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا البدايه من القرار الذي ورد قبل
ثوان عن الفيدرالي الامريكي والذي رفع فيه
سعر الفائده بربع نقطه مئويه اذا كل
التوقعات والترجيحات كانت تشير الى رفع
سعر الفائده برفع نقطه مئويه وبالتالي هو
تراجع من نصف نقطه الى ربع نقطه طبعا لم
يكن متوقع بان لا يرفع الفائده لان ذلك
ممكن ان ينظر يعني اشياء وتداعيات سلبيه
على الاقتصاد طبعا سيكون لنا وقفه بعد
قليل مع الزملاء بقسم الاقتصاد
لشرح ماهيه هذا الرفع وكيف سينعكس على
البنوك بعد ازمه يعني تهاوي عدد كبير من
البنوك ان كان في الولايات المتحده واخرها
بنك سويس بنك في سويسرا طبعا كما قلت تم
رفع سعر الفائده ربع نقطه مئويه بعدما كان
الرفعه الاخير بمقدار نصف نقطه
اعيد واذكر بان هذا كل التقديرات
والترجيحات كانت تشير الى الرفع بربع
النقطه لان عدم الرفع بظل كل ما يعانيها
اليوم الاقتصاد وازمه البنوك كانت ستنظر
بان هناك مشكله كبرى يعرفها الفيدرالي ولا
يريد ان يقول للناس اذا بالسياقه التاسعه
سنكون مع زملاءنا بقسم الاقتصاد وتحديدا
الزميله نادين الهاني للحديث عن هذا الرفع
بالعوده الى التاسعه مشاهدينا الصراع
النووي في العالم بات اقرب من اي وقت مضى
والسبب كما قالت الخارجيه الروسيه فهو
امداد بريطانيا بذخائر اليورانيوم المنظم
قال ان قرار بريطانيا بتزويد اوكرانيا
بقذائف من اليورانيوم المنضب يعد ويصعد
الموقف الى مستويات جديده وخطيره
وسيؤدي الى عواقب وخيمه على علاقات موسكو
ولندن لافراف بهذه التصريحات اتت بعدما اك
د وزير الخارجيه البريطاني جيمس كلافري في
وقت سابق عدم وجود اي تصعيد نوويه يتعلق
بدعم اوكرانيا باليورانيوم المنظم
هذه خطوه نحو مزيد من التصعيد نحو تصعيد
خطير وكمي وصدرت تصريحات لبعض المسؤولين
الغربيين يقولون فيها انه لا يوجد شيء
مخيف في ذلك وان قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
لم تكن محظوره وانهم لا يخالفون اي
اتفاقيات لكن الجميع يتذكرون نتائج
استخدام قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم في
يوغوسلافيا والعراق عندما اصيب عشرات
الالاف من المدنيين وجنود الناتو الذين
استخدموا قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم تلك
من جانبه صرح الرئيس البالروسيه
بانه في حلقه بريطانيا بامداد اوكرانيا
بقذائف اليورانيوم المنظم فستقم روسيا
بامداد منسك بقذائفه تحتوي على يورانيوم
حقيقي وقال لوكاشينكو تعليقا على تصريحات
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه حول عزمها تزويد
اوكرانيا بقذائف محشوه بيورانيوم منضب قال
اذا ما زود الغرب اوكرانيا بقذائف محشوه
باليورانيوم المنظم فان روسيا لن تتاخر في
تزويدنا
بذخيره محشوه
بيورانيوم حقيقيه
بقذائف تحتوي على اليورانيوم المنظم
قرارهم بريطانيه واجه انتقادات دوليه
وتهديدات روسيه لكن ما هي قذائف
اليورانيوم المنظم او المستنفذ وهل هي
اسلحه ذات مكونات نوويه كما قال الرئيس
الروسي
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه دافعت عن هذا
القرار قائله بان هذه القنابل او قنابل
ذخائر خارقه للدروع تحتوي على يورانيوم
منظم وهو مكون معتاد لا علاقه له بالاسلحه
النوويه ومستخدم منذ عقود كما هو معلوم
بحسبها تصنيع هيكل هذه القنابل يعتمد على
عناصر اليورانيوم الثقيل والذي يعد اكثر
كثافه من الرصاص وبالتالي قوه اكبر اثناء
الاصطدام ونار كثيفه اثناء عمليه الاختراق
هذه الذخائر مشاهدينا بغايه الفاعليه
لتدمير دبابات ومدرعات حديثه وهي معدله
للاستخدام بواسطه دبابات كما نشاهد هنا
التي تعتزم طبعا لندن تزويد اكياف بها
ايضا الا ان القذائف اليورانيوم المنظمه
عدم وجود حظر دولي عليها فهي تنطوي على
مخاطر تهدد صحه العسكريين الذين
يستخدمونها في مناطق النزاع ومناطق القصف
الامم المتحده تصنف اليورانيوم المنظم
كمعدن ثقيل سام كيميائي واشعاعي باعتباره
المنتج الثانوي الرئيسي المتبقي بعد عمليه
تخصيب اليورانيوم نفس خصائص
الكيميائيه لكن خصائص اشعاعيه اقل فهنا
وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه وصفت قرار
البريطاني لنقل قذائف اليورانيوم المنظم
الى اوكرانيا بتكرار لسيناريو اليوغوسلافي
اي حرب كوسوفو عام
1969 حينها القي ما يقارب 15 طنا من
اليورانيوم المستنفذ خلال ثلاثه اشهر ما
تسبب بتلويث الانهار وارتفاع معدل الاصابه
بالاورام الخبيثه كاسر رفضات الدم والرئه
وايضا تلف الكلى
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا قبل ان انتقل الى موسكو وزميله
انتقل الى هذه الصور المباشره من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه عن عمليه اطلاق نار
وطعن باحدى الثانويات
بمقاطعه الامريكيه وطبعا كما نشاهد تجمهر
للسكان المحليين هناك وطبعا ذوي الطلبه
موجودين في الخارج ولم يعلم حتى الساعه
حصيله هذه العمليه او تفاصيل وطبعا
سنوافيكم بها بعد قليل خلال هذه
التغطيه وايضا طبعا الشرطه وصلت الى هناك
لنتابع بعد قليل ما الذي سيحصل وان كان
هناك قتلى او جرحى بهذه العمليه
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى الموضوع
الروسيه الاوكرانيه سنضم الينا من موسكو
كاتيا طعم ممارسه العربيه كاتيا التصعيد
الجديد اليوم بين موسكو وبريطانيا حول
عمليه تسليم هذه القنابل ما الجديد فيه
ويعني هل هناك اي تطورات جديده بهذا
الموضوع
مرحبا ليال بالفعل كان هناك اليوم تصريحات
وردود
رسميه من قبل موسكو على الاعلان البريطاني
حول
نواياها تزويد اوكرانيا بقذائف اليورانيوم
طبعا كان هناك تصريح اول بالنسبه لرئيس
روسيا يوم امس كان قد قال ان موسكو ستقوم
بالرد في حال تم استخدام هذه القذائف
النوويه واتهم لندن طبعا بانها ستقوم
بالقتال هناك محاربه روسيا حتى اخر
اوكرانيا طبعا من جانبه ايضا وزير الدفاع
الروسيس كان قد قال ان العالم اصبح اقرب
بخطوه لحدوث مواجهه نوويه باعتبار ان
القوه والنوويه وهي احد
تقول دائما انها ملتزمه بالمعاهده عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه ولكنها في حال تمت
تهديد موسكو ستكون بالرد طبعا على هذه لو
سمحتي باختصار موضوع المبادره الصينيه
للسلام ثلاثه ايام لم يحكى اي شيء عن هذا
الموضوع هل اي من هناك اي تفاصيل او
تسريبات حول هذه النقطه بالتحديد
بالفعل عيال اولا تصريحات لندن هي تاتي
بالتوازي مع زياره الرئيس الصيني الى الى
الى موسكو كان هناك طبعا كما تطرق
الجانبان او تطرق خلال البيان النهائي يوم
امس الى ان هذه
الخطه السلميه التي طرحتها الصين يمكن ان
تكون كقاعده فيما بعد للعمل عليها ولكن لم
يرشح اي شيء جديد لان كما قال الرئيس
الروسي بوتين ان هذه القاعده يمكن العمل
عليها فقط ان كان هناك اتوجه ايجابي من
قبل الغرب ورد ايجابي من قرب اوكرانيا
والذي حتى الان لم تشهده كما تقول موسكو
هناك طبعا بالعكس تصعيد من قبل الغرب
وبالاخص في ظل ايضا تصريحات لندن تزويدها
القذائف النوويه لقذائف اليورانيوم الى
كييف شكرا لك كاتيا العربيه حدثنا من
موسكو
حفل مبهرج واستعراض وتبجج لبى المجرد فرصه
لالتقاط الصور اوصاف الصقت بزياره الرئيس
الصيني الى روسيا فصحيفه ديليجراف
البريطانيه اكدت ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين لم يحصل على الكثير من
زياره نظيره الصيني واضافت ان البيان
المشترك للرئيسين الصيني والروسيه يشير
الى ان القاده لم يحققوا اي اختراقات
كبيره خصوصا في الملف الاوكراني حيث لم
تتضمن الزياره التي دامت ثلاثه ايام اي
اعلان مفاجئ عن دعم عسكري من بكين لموسكو
وخلت طبعا من مناوره دبلوماسيه صينيه
مفاجئه بشان محادثات السلام وبقيت بخانه
الوسيط الحاسم مجاملات من الجانبين مملوءه
بنفس العبارات الماليه حول شراكه بلا حدود
وصداقه واهداف مشتركه وزياده الصفقات
التجاريه لتبقى الصفقات التجاريه الموقعه
العامل الوحيد المساعد لروسيا في مواجهه
الجفاف الاقتصادي المستمر في زمن الحرب
والعقوبات طبعا لكن ابرز ما كان واضحا
خلال اجتماعات الرئيسين الروسي والصيني هو
التاكيد على حقبه جديده وعالم متعدد
الاقطاب ووفقه مراقبين هنا رحله الرئيس
الصيني الى موسكو لعبت لصالح بلاده اكثر
من ملاعبت لصالح روسيا على الاقل علنا
فيما قيل خلف الابواب المغلقه فهو طبعا
غير معروف
[موسيقى]
رغم استقلال القوات الاوكرانيه في الحصول
على دبابات غربيه لصد هجوم من روسيا كبير
محتمل الا ان نجاح القتال البري لا يعتمد
على الدبابات وحدها بل مدى جوده تكامل
الدبابات مع بقيه المعدات وافقه
فمركبات المشاه القتاليه وفق الصحيفه اهم
من الدبابات بالنسبه لاوكرانيا واكثر
الحاحا هذه المركبات اخف تسليحا من
الدبابات ومصممه طبعا للتقدم مع الدبابات
الثقيله في المعارك لحمايتها من العدو
وهنا الولايات المتحده اعلنت في يناير
الماضي تزويد كيا بمدرعات تسمى باسم
برادلي والتي يمكنها ان توفر غطاء للجنود
الاوكرانيين
ومركبه برادلي طبعا كما هو معلوم هي اسرع
من الدبابات القتاليه وادخلت للخدمه عام
وتمتلك واشنطن اسطولا منها بالالاف هنا
خبراء عسكريون اوضحوا بان مناورات الاسلحه
المشتركه بالدبابات والمركبات القتاليه
تساعد باختراق خط المواجهه الروسيه وتقليل
الاحتياجات الاوكرانيه لذخيره المدفعيه
وطبعا تقدير الخسائر
[موسيقى]
دعا وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه دول اوروبا
والحليفه الاعتقال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين وتقديمه للمحاكمه اذا زار اي دول
اوروبيه او دول حليفه اخرى بالعالم وكانت
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه قد اصدرت قبل
ايام مذكره اعتقال بحق بوتين كما اوضح
بلينكن ان دعم الصين السياسي والمديل
روسيا يتعرض ويتعارض مع مصالح واشنطن
مضيفا انا بكين لم تتجاوز بعد الخط الاحمر
لتسليم موسكو اسلحه فتاكه
[موسيقى]
اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسيه انه تم نشر
انظمه دفاع جوي في احدى جزر الكوريل
المتنازع عليها مع اليابان خلال ديسمبر
الماضي بهدف انشاء منطقه للسيطره على
الوضع بطول سواحل
لقد زدنا قدراتنا في المنطقه العسكريه
الشرقيه بشكل كبير فخلال العام الماضي
زودت بنحو 400 قطعه عسكريه حديثه كما انه
لضمان استمرار التحكم بالمنطقه على طول
سواحل الجزر الكوريل تم نشر مجموعه من
انظمه الصواريخ الدفاعيه في جزيره بالوشير
في ديسمبر من العام 2022
اجرت القوات الامريكيه والكوريه الجنوبيه
تدريبات مشتركه بالذخيره الحاجه في اطار
المناورات العسكريه المشتركه تحت اسم درع
الحريه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت سلوفاكي انها حصلت من الولايات
المتحده على عرض اسلحه تتجاوز قيمتها
مليار دولار بسعر مخفض وذلك بديلا من
ثلاثه عشره مقاتله
بتسليمها لاوكرانيا واوضح وزير الدفاع
لسلوفاكي ان عرض الاسلحه يشمل اثنتي عشره
مروحيه جديده من طراز بل اي اتش
زد واي
فايبر عفوا مع ملحقات وتدريب طيارين
وتقنيين اضافه الى اكثر من 500 صاروخ وهي
من نوع agm
صوت البرلمان السويدي بالتاييد لعضويه
البلاد في الناتو وذلك وفق الموقع
الالكتروني للبرلمان وصوت 269 نائبا
انضمام الى التحالف الى 37 ضد حيث عارض
اعضاء حزب اليسار وحزب حمايه البيئه
انضمام البلاد الى الناتو وتعد هذه الخطوه
هي الاخيره محليا دون ان تصبح سويد جزءا
من التحالف العسكري الغربي المكون من 30
عضوا
مشاهدينا التاسعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
[تصفيق]
انهيار الليره يحرك الشارع اللبناني
والامن يواجه المحتاجين بالغاز
[موسيقى]
مياه اضافيه مقابل التنسيق ضد تواجد حزب
العمال الكردستاني في العراق عرض مشروط تم
التوصل اليه لاتفاق حوله وعاد رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شاع السوداني قادما
من تركيا فخلال زيارته الى انقره اعلن
السوداني انه حصل على ما يريده العراق
طبعا من كميات اضافيه من المياه المتدفقه
من تركيا الى نهري دجله والفرات وان كانت
تلك الكميات محدوده الا انها مكسب وفق
الوصف الحكومي بالعراق خصوصا بعد معاشت
البلاد سنوات من الجفاف رئيس الوزراء
العراقيه محمد شياع السوداني اعتبر اعلان
الرئيس التركي حول زياده تدفقات المياه
نجاح لتوجهات الحكومه مؤكدا في ذات الوقت
انه يعمل على تامين حصص العراق من حقه في
المياه عبر الحوارات هذا ابرز ما حصل عليه
السوداني خلال زيارته
المشاهدينا ما الذي قدمه مقابل هذا العرض
المحدود قال هنا اعلام تركي ان السوداني
قدم ضمانات على ان يصنف العراق حزب العمال
الكردستاني منظمه ارهابيه والتنسيق
المشترك على طرد المقاتلين الاكراد من
اقليم اي كردستان تحديدا من سنجار اضافه
الى ان التنسيق حول ضبط الحدود والتعاون
المشترك بين كل طبعا من تركيا والعراق
خاصه في الجانب الاستخباراتي وتبادل
المعلومات على الحدود بين البلدين وشدد
السودان على انه لن يسمح بان تتحول اراضي
العراق الى مصدر تهديد لدول الجوار
المباحثات شهدت تناول
الملف الامني نرتبط مع تركيا
بحدود طويله
تجاوز 300 كيلومتر
وهنا اود ان اؤكد ان العراق ملتزم بعدم
السماح لاستخدام اراضيه كمنطلق
للاعتداء على تركيا
والامن امن المنطقه هو امن واحد لا يتجزا
ومن خلال التعاون الاستخباراتي وتبادل
معلومات بالتاكيد سوف نحل هذه المشاكل
الامنيه بعيدا عن استخدام العنف
وبما يحافظ على امن وسياده العراق التي
نحرص على تحقيقها وان لا تؤثر على علاقتنا
وتوجهاتنا الكبيره
والجاده لتطوير العلاقه بين العراق وتركيا
ينضم الينا مشاهدينا من بغداد الدكتور
حسين علاوي مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي
دكتور يعني قبل الحديث عن الجانب التقني
والذي هو جانب المياه كم يعني موضوع
التصحر وحاجه العراق اليوم بالجانب
السياسي ما الذي حصل عليها الجانب التركي
مقابل اعطاء العراق هذه الحصه من المياه
هل هناك تضحيه بالاكراد على الحدود
الشماليه
يعني مساء الخير عليكم مساء الخير على
المشاهدين الكرام وكل عام وتحديدا يعني
مقاتلين حزب العمال الكردستاني
لا تسمحي لي هو هو صوره اكبر من الزياره
في صورتها اكبر يعني هدف سيد رئيس وزراء
كان هدف اقتصادي بحث في عمليه انه تعزيز
اولا العلاقات هذه اول زياره للسيد رئيس
وزراء الى تركيا في اطار زيارته الاقليميه
التي زار بها دول الجوار وكذلك بالمقابل
الزياره ركزت على مسار المياه والتعامل
معه كملف فني وواضح جدا كان كلام السيد
رئيس وزراء الاستاذ محمد الشياع السوداني
في ان مركز المياه المشترك ما بين وزاره
الموارد المائيه بين الوزاره المناظره له
في الحكومه التركيه هو من يعمل على تقدير
الموقف ويعمل كذلك على دعم القرارات
المشتركه في اطار الحوارات التي يجريها
العراق مع تركيا في هذا الوجه وكذلك
بالمقابل المسار الاكبر وهو قضيه طريق
التنميه القناه الجافه التي تاتي من ميناء
الفاول الكبير الذي يرتكز على مدينه
صناعيه كبرى نحو تركيا ومن ثم العالم نحو
اوروبا عفوا ومن ثم العالم ان يربط بين
والغرب من خلال هذا الطريق وطبعا تبقى
قضيه اتفاق سنجار الذي هو اتفاق ما بين
الحكومه الاتحاديه وحكومه اقليم كردستان
ومواطنين الموجودين في سنجار والتكوينات
السياسيه في سنجار ان نمضي في عمليه فرض
القانون نمضي في بناء المنشات الامنيه
نمضي في قطه اعمار سنجار وكذلك الخطه
الكبيره كذلك في مسك الخط الصفري العراقي
التركي من خلال المخافر الحدوديه التي عمل
عليها السيد رئيس وزراء خلال الاشهر
الماضيه دكتور علاوي بموضوع المياه بما
انك تتحدث عن الجانب التقني للبحث اليوم
ما قدمه جانب التركي هو قليل جدا نسبه
لحاجه العراق من المياه نتحدث عن مئات
ومليارات يعني المكعبات التي بحاجه لها
العراق اليوم وايضا الجانب التركي اعلم
باكثر من مره بان التصحر هو السبب الاساسي
بالجفاف الموجود بالعراق وليس ما قامت به
تركيا من بناء سدود ما الخارق الذي يعني
حدث هنا
غير موضوع يعني المساومه بين السياسه
والجانب التقني
لا اكيد العراق جرب على مدى الاربعين سنه
الماضيه حقيقه السياسه وكذلك
التلويح بادوات متعدده غير غير السياسه
لكن لم يصل الى نقطه نقطه حقيقيه في هذا
الحوار اتوقع ان السيد محمد الشياع
السوداني في البرنامج الحكومي هو يركز على
ان تكون هنالك حوارات فنيه هذه الحوارات
الفنيه ممكن ان تبني مدارك مشتركه
وبالتالي تحل مشكله المياه لانه مشكله
المياه هي تعمل الان مقابل مسار اخر يعمل
عليه سيد رئيس وزراء والحكومه العراقيه
وهو المسار الاقتصادي جذب المشاريع
الاستثماريه التركيه داخل العراق كذلك
بالمقابل جذب وتكوين هذا الطريق
الاستراتيجي الذي سيغير من خارطه التجاره
الدوليه بصوره كبيره جدا وكذلك تعزيز
التجاره البينيه ما بين العراق وتركيا هي
عوامل دافعه حقيقه للجانب التركي في زياده
الدفعات المائيه من جهه وفي كذلك حصول
العراق على الحصص كامله التي يستحقها
وتحقق كذلك بالمقابل حاله الاكتفاء الخاصه
بمياه شرب او كذلك مياه استخدام في
الزراعه وكذلك خطه رئيس الوزراء في
المشاريع الاروائيه الكبرى حتى ان السيد
رئيس الجمهوريه كان يتحدث من نيويورك عن
هذا الموضوع وخطه الحكومه العراقيه في هذا
المسار وبالتالي هنالك مركب من المشاريع
تعمل عليه الحكومه العراقيه من خلال
مسارات متعدده ان كان على الجانب الفني
وهي مشاريع روائيه متقدمه على الجانب
التقني وهي جذب التقنيات الجديده
وكذلك في قضيه تطوير القنوات المائيه
العراقيه حتى يعني رئيس الجمهوريه بهذا
الموضوع كان قد لوح بمقاضاه تركيا لان
نتحدث عن اكثر من 42 مليون عراقي اليوم
مهددين بالتصحر ويعني قطاعات عده مهدده
بالزوال ولكن يعني بهذه يعني بهذا المحور
اليوم موضوع
يعني المقاتلين بشماليه تركيا يعتبر موضوع
امن قومي بالنسبه لتركيا وبالتالي لا يمكن
ان تعطي اي ضمانات باي موضوع اخر او تطوير
اخر دون ضمانات بهذا الموضوع ما الضمانات
التي اعطيت هنا
يعني اكيد نحن نركز الان حقيقه كحكومه
عراقيه وقرار القاده العامه للقوات
المسلحه السيد محمد الشاعر السوداني في ان
ننهي هذه التركه الثقيله على مدى الاربعين
سنه وعلى مدى الوقت الزمن الذي امتدت منذ
2013 ولم تحل لغايه الان اتوقع انه هنالك
الان حلول من خلال تواجد القوات المسلحه
العراقيه الجيش العراقي في سنجار كذلك مسك
الحدود من خلال قوات حرس الحدود
وقوات البشمرقه وهذا التعاون ياتي
اللوائين العسكريان اللذان سيشكلان خلال
المرحله المقبله في المناطق المشتركه
وكذلك بالمقابل عوده الحياه المدنيه
والاجتماعيه في سنجار هذا كفيل حقيقه
بانهاء ملف المسلحين وكذلك بالمقابل
عمليات فرض القانون التي تقوم بها القوات
العراقيه هذا سيحود من هذه الظاهره
المسلحه على المثلث العراقي السوري التركي
وبالتالي لن يعطي مبرر حقيقه للجانب
التركي او كذلك لهذه الجماعات ان تتخذ
الاراضي بالاضافه الى تطبيق قوانين خاصه
باللاجئين ان كانت القوانين العراقيه او
الدستور او كذلك القوانين الدوليه
وتطبيقاتها بان يكون هنالك لاجئين من دون
سلاح وهذا مهم جدا لكل من يخير بهذا
الاتجاه شكرا لك يا دكتور حسين علاوي
مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي على هذه
المداخله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا
بالانتقال الى موضوع
الادعاء على الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب نقلا عن سي ان ان المدعي
العام يقول بانه اجل توجيه الاتهام لترامب
اليوم لتقديم ادله اضافيه طبعا هذا بعد
الانباء التي كنا نتحدث عنها بانه هناك
احتمال لتوجيه الاتهام اليومي واحتمال
توقيف ترامب اليوم سنعود الى هذا الموضوع
طبعا بالسياق نشرات العربيه ولكن كما
ذكرنا في بدايه ان نشره الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي رفع اسعار الفائده بنسبه 25
نقطه اساس المزيد طبعا من التحليل حول
تبعات قرار الفيدرالي على الاسواق تنضم
الينا الزميله نادين هاني من قسم الاقتصاد
نادين يعني هذا الرفع كان متوقع كيف
سيتلقفه او ستتلقفه الاسواق بعد ازمه
البنوك الاخيره وهل هناك رفع اخر متوقع
ليان لا شك بانه من بعض الاحداث الاخيره
اصلا كان تغيرت التوقعات يعني بالاجتماع
السابق كنا نتوقع ان يرفع الفيدرالي
بخمسين نقطه اساس من بعد ازمه البنوك
تتراجعت التوقعات الى ربع نقطه مئويه
الفيدرالي لا يفاجئ الاسواق عاده اذا كان
احتماليه بالسوق توقعات 85% كانت انه يرفع
ربع نقطه مئويه بالفعل هو بيرفع مثل
توقعات السوق لا يحب مفاجاه الاسواق
بالنسبه لهم مهم جدا مع الاسواق ممكن ان
تعطي رساله خاطئه للاسواق هو اللي تغير هو
التوقعات المستقبليه رح فسر الان شو اللي
تغير بالكلام بالنسبه للرفع المستقبلي خفت
التوقعات الان بالنسبه لحجم الرفع
بالاجتماعات القادمه فلنستمع لك نادين
تفاصيل معك تفضلي شكرا ليال اذا مشاهدينا
رفع البنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي قبل قليل
اسعار الفائده بربع نقطه مئويه لتصل الى
5% هي الاعلى منذ العام 2007 جاء قرار
الفيدرالي متماشيا كما ذكرنا مع اغلب
توقعات المحللين على الرغم من مطالبات عدى
بوقف رفع اسعار الفائده خاصه بعد ازمه
تعثر ثلاثه بنوك امريكيه الاسبوع الماضي
واستبدل بيان الفيدرالي عباره رفع مستمر
للفائده بالنسبه للتوقعات المستقبليه
استبدلها بتوقعات الاعضاء بان المزيد من
التشديد في السياسه النقديه قد يكون
مناسبا للوصول بتضخم الى مستوى اثنين
بالمئه وتعليقا على الازمه الحاليه للبنوك
اشار البيان الى ان القطاع المصرفي متين
لكن الاحداث الاخيره ممكن ان تؤدي الى
تشديد في شروط الائتمان وتاثير سلبي على
النمو الا ان حجم تاثير لا يزال غير واضح
فاذا لنذهب الان الى المؤتمر الصحفي ليجي
رومبا ولا الذي بدا الان لنستمع الى ما
سيقول رئيس الاحتياط الخضروري
ولهذا السبب وردا على هذه الاحداث فان
الفيدرالي وبالعمل مع وزاره الخزانه قد
قرر على العمل على حمايه الاقتصاد
الامريكي ونظامنا المصرفي هذه الاجراءات
تظهر ان نظامنا المصرفي لا يزال لا يزال
امنا وبدعم من الخزانه الامريكيه ومن خلال
برنامج تمويل المصارف لضماني ان المصارف
تمتلك اصول ضروريه واقراض ممكن
عندما تدعو الحاجه فان هذا البرنامج فضلا
عن البرامج الخصم الاخرى هي ضروريه من اجل
الوفاء باحتياجات التمويل التي تواجهها
بعض المصارف ومن الواضح بانها تضخ السيوله
المطلوبه في النظام ان النظام المصرفي قوي
وقادر على الصمود ويتمتع بالسيول وسوف
نستمر بمراقبه الاوضاع في النظام المصرفي
وسوف نستخدم كافه الادوات من اجل ضمان
سلامته بالاضافه الى ذلك اننا ملتزمون في
تعلم الدروس والعمل لمنعه اي احداث مشابهه
مثل تلك من تكرار نفسها
هو من خلال
نعيشه في الاقتصاد بصوت عامه فان تضخم
مرتفعا وحتى اللحظه فان زملائي فانا نتفهم
مدى صعوبات التي يحدثها هذا التضخم وان
مازلنا ملتزمين بالعمل على اعاده التضخم
الى مستواه الاصلي اثنين في المئه
الاستقرار هو من مسؤوليه الاحتياطي ومن
خلال دون هذا الصقر لا يمكن للفدراري ان
يستمر ادائمها ولا سيما انه بدون
الاستقرار لا يمكننا ان نحقق فتره مستدامه
في الظروف في ظروف السوق التي تعود بالنفع
على الجميع ان الاقتصاد الامريكي قد تباطى
قليلا في العمل الماضي حيث كانت قدر ارتفع
اجمال الناتج المحلي بواقع 0.9 وانفاق
المستهلكين كان قد ارتفع رغم ان هذه القوه
قد تنعكست
بمعنى نهايه العام وعلى النقيض من ذلك فان
الانشطه في قطاع المساكن لا تزال ضعيفه هو
بسبب نسبه الرهن العقاري
الفوائد المرتفعه
يمكن تلمسها ايضا من خلال تاثيرها على
الشركات وتتوقع الشركات بان النمو سوف
يزداد ومن خلال توقعاتنا
على المدى المتوسط لرفوع لرفع اجمال
الناتج المحلي ان يكون بواقع 0.4 في هذا
العام
وهذا كاليكون هو التقدير على المدى الطويل
وكافه المشاركين يرون ان نسبه اجمال
الناتج المحلي قد يكون باتجاه النزولي في
العام القادم لكن السوق
والوظائف
كانت قد ارتفعت بواقع 350,000 وظيفه في
الاشهر الثلاثه الماضيه
وهذا يشكل زياده بواقع ثلاثه فاصل ثلاثه
فاصل سته في المئه ونسبه المشاركه العماله
وزياده الاجور كانت قد اجرت اظهرت نوعا من
تخفيف القيود
هو الطلب على العمل لا يزال كبيرا حتى
اللحظه
ومن خلال توقعي المشاركين على حجم الطلب
في السوق بانه سوف يحقق نوعا من التوازن
مما يخفف من حده القيود
وتوقعات التوظيف بان ترتفع الى 4.2% في
نهايه العام الحالي واربعه فاصل سته في
المئه في العام المقبل التضخم يبقى اعلى
من ما هو يعني منصوص عليه بنسبه 2% وفي
مطلع يناير
كانت اسعار المواد الغذائيه واسعار الطاقه
قدر ارتفعت بصوره واضحه
رئيس الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لمشاهدينا جيرون
باولر ان اثنين بالمئه هو المستوى
المستهدف للتضخم هذا عكس ما كان يتوقع
البعض انه ممكن ان يغير الانفليشن
وبالتالي لا نزال الان يتحدث عن اثنين
بالمئه هذا يعني انهم مستمرون بمحاربه
التضخم ولو انه اشار الى موضوع الازمه
الماليه خليني اعطي بعض يعني ملفت نظري
حتى الان بالقرار فاذا رفع بربع نقطه
مئويه هذا كان متوقعا تغيير بالريتوريك
بدل ما كانوا يتحدثوا عن انغوينجريت هايكس
يعني استمرار بالرفع استبدلوها بجمله انه
الاعضاء بالفدراليه يرون انه بعض الرفع قد
يكون ملائما لاعاده التضخم الاثنين بالمئه
فاذا خففوا اللهجه بالنسبه لرفع المستقبلي
اشاروا الى متانه القطاع المصرفي ولكن
بنفس الوقت اشاروا الى انه ما يحدث
بالقطاع المصرفي سيؤدي الى تراجع
بالائتمان الممنوح وهذا بدوره قد يؤثر
سلبا على نمو يعني
ولكن يقولون انه اكسنت
يعني لا يدرون بكم سيكون تاثيرها نتيجه
الازمه الماليه ايضا لفت نظري انه عم
نتحدث عنها اسعار الفائده لتصل اليها
الفائده مع نهايه 2024 تركوها عن 5.1% كما
بالاجتماع السابق اما بنهايه 2024
الان رفعوا التوقعات للفائده التي ستكون
عليها الاسعار بنهايه 2024 الى
4.3% من 4.1% سابقا خلينا نشوف رد فعل
الاسواق عوائد سندات الخزانه على مدار
عامين هي اللي كان فيها رد الفعل الاعنف
راينا ارتفاعات على اسواق الاسهم الان
الاسهم على ارتفاع بربع نقطه مئويه الناس
على ارتفاع بنصف نقطه مئويه لانه الاسواق
اعتبرت انه الكلام يشير الى امكانيه
التمهل بالرفع
وتوقعات الان بانه سيتم هناك تخفيض
للفائده قبل نهايه السنه ومن هنا شو عم
نشوف ارتفاعها على الاسهم ولاحظوا عائد
السنتين قبل قرار الفيدرالي كان عند 4.15
يتداول الان عند اربعه صفر اثنين عائد
سندات الخزانه على مدار عامين شفت فيه رد
الفعل الاعنف ايضا الان عم شوف على عشر
سنوات كان عن ثلاثه فاصل خمسه وخمسين قبل
القرار الان 3-49 الدولار على تراجع خلينا
نشوف اسعار العملات ها هو اليورو والباوند
هلا الباوند قصه مختلفه لان تضخم كان عالي
ببريطانيا مثل ما عم نشوف على الشاشه
المركزي السعودي لاحقا برفع الفائده برفع
نقطه اساس القطري ايضا والبحرين
لتعليق حول قرار الفيدرا لينضم الي من
القاهره السيد وائل زياد الرئيس التنفيذي
لشركه ازيلا كابيتال اهلا بك وائل هل يعني
برايك لماذا الاسواق تفهم انه في امكانيه
تخفيض للفائده قبل نهايه السنه هذا ما
يقوله لنا الان عائد سنتين رد الفعل عم
نشوفه بالسندات لماذا يعني فهم كلامه على
انه دوفش في امكانيه سياسه تيسيريه اكثر
من السابق
لان الحقيقه هو ذكر اكتر من مره في كلمته
ان اهميه الحفاظ على الهلس او البنك مسكت
او
القطاع المصرفي النقطه الثانيه ان زي ما
ذكرتي حضرتك احنا كان في توقع بنصف نقطه
ولو احنا بصينا على استطلاعات هنلاقي ان
التوقع بنصف نقطه زياده تعدى كان في
الفتره السابقه قبل موضوع سلك بنك تعدى
الخمسين في الميه النهارده كنت بتفرج على
التوقعات
ربع نقطه كان هو المرجح وكانوا مرجحينه
بنسبه 62% بل في نقطه ثانيه مهمه ايضا ان
احتمال الارتفاع لخمسه وربع في المئه يعني
ربع نقطه اخرى
مرجح بنسبه
62% زي ما حضرتك ذكرتي الفيدرالي لا فجاءت
الاسواق وبالتالي الاسواق توقعت ان اذا
ارتفع بنسبه ربع في ربع هيكون في اتجاه
الى انخفاض بعكس ما سبق وهو الارتفاع بنصف
فنصف اخر ثم بدايه التخفيض من عشرين اربعه
وعشرين وهي دي المفاجاه اللي يمكن حتى مش
قادر اقول ان الاسواق بتحتفل بها ولكن
الاسواق في حاله يعني
الى حد ما لان لو شفت زي ما تابعنا في بعد
القرار الناس ارتفع
اكثر من كده وبعد كدهوت رجعوا في هبوط
تاني بيقفل او مش يقفله يعني يحافظوا على
ارتفاعات اقل من صفر فاصل واحد في المئه
ولا شك بانه بالكيوي بعد قليل راح يكون
ملفت اذا سال عن ازمه المصارف ما الذي
سيقول بهذا الاتجاه كلام اللي معاد سابقا
بالبيان هو انه
القطاع متين
لكن لا شك بانه ما يجري بالقطاع المصرفي
رح يؤدي الى
بس مش معروف كم حجم التايتنك هنا سؤالي لك
وائل الى اي مدى تعتقد انه ما يحدث
بالنظام المصري في سيؤدي الى تراجع نسبه
الائتمان الممنوح وبالتالي هذا رح يؤدي
الى تراجع الطلب وبدوره يكون الافكت تبعه
كانه في رفع للفائده يعني على الاقتصاد
ككل على التضخم بحد ذاته هون ما وجهه نظرك
بهذه النقطه لا طبعا ما يحدث حاليا في
القطاع المصرفي هيؤدي الى تراجع كبير جدا
وهنشوفه واتصور في ارقام
ابريل بشكل اكبر في الائتمانات الممنوحه
في القطاع المصرفي وده بدوره هيؤدي الى
تراجع الى بدايه التراجع في النمو ولكن في
هذا الصدر حابب ان انا اقول نقطه اخر عشر
سنين النمو في الحجم الدين العالمي في
النظام المصرفي العالمي كان اكثر من 3
مرات احنا النهارده ل 300 تريليون تريليون
دولار في الديون في القطاع المصرفي
العالمي اللي بدا يعلن بما يحدث حاليا ان
هو لا يستطيع ان يقترب مره اخرى من الخمسه
في الميه او يظل عند الخمسه في الميه معدل
فوائد
الى مدى طويل تخوفي الحقيقه هو لو اصر
الفيدرالي على مجابهه التضخم عن طريق رفع
الفوائد او الابقاء عليها مرتفعه بشكل
يفاجئ الاسواق او اكثر مما هو متوقع حاليا
ان هو لن يصل قريبا الى مستوى الاثنين في
الميه وده الكونفرتزون بتاع الفيدرالي
ولكن هيكون لها تبعات قاسيه جدا في اسواق
المال
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد وائل زياده رئيسه
التنفيذي لشركه ازيلا كابيتال مشاهدينا
قبل ان اكمل او اختم هذه الفقره اشاره الى
انه ابقى الفيدرالي على الكونتيت
اللي هو
اللي بتستحق شهريا ب 60 مليار دولار سندات
الخزانه لا يعيد تجديدها
30 مليار يعني ما زاد حجم
رغم انه من ناحيه اخرى هو يمنح البنوك
الان خطوط ائتمان عبر الديسكونت منذ اللي
عملها من بعد تعثر المصارف فبالتالي هذه
الديناميكيه ايضا سنناقشها غدا ببرامج
الاسواق ولكن الان نعود اليك ليال
واستكمال الاخبار شكرا لكن الدين يعني
اخبار افضل مما كنا نتوقع بهذا القرار
شكرا لكن نادين هاني على هذه الفقره
[موسيقى]
قال اليوم رئيس لجنه تحقيق عامه تنظر في
مزاعم خطيره جدا بارتكاب القوات
البريطانيه عشرات من جرائم القتل خارج
نطاق القانون في افغانستان ان اي جندي خلف
القانون سيخضع لتحقيق واضاف رئيس لجنه
التحقيق القاضي تشارلز هاردن ان المزاعم
التي يجب على اللجنه النظر فيها اشيرا الى
ان لجنه ستنظر طبعا في مدى صحه تحقيقات
التي اجرتها الشرطه العسكريه وما اذا كان
قد تم التستر على اي جرائم قتل غير
قانونيه في افغانستان في الوقت ذاته اما
الولايات المتحده فقال وزير خارجيته
انطوني بلينكن فان الخارجيه تدعو مراجعه
او تعد مراجعه
تعد مراجعه حول الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان وستقدم النتائج للكونجرس بحلول
منتصف ابريل
التاسع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
توجيه الاتهامات للترامب يتاجل هيئه
المحلفين الخاصه بالقضيه لن تجتمع اليوم
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اغلقت موانئ مرسيليا وهي
واحده من اكبر الموانئ في فرنسا كجزء من
حمله الموانئ الميته التي دعا اليها اتحاد
النقابات الفرنسيه وذلك بعد ما حاصر عمال
الرصيف والموانئ منع واغلق طريق الوصول
الى هذا الميناء بواسطه خمس حاويات
منعت الشرطه الفرنسيه مسيره طلابيه مناهضه
لقانون التقاعد الجديد من الوصول الى
جامعه وسط باريس وانطلقت المسيره طبعا من
ادام امام وزاره التربيه والتعليم وضمت
مئات الطلبه والمدرسين الا ان الشرطه
منعتهم من مغادره المكان صوب الجامعه
والالتقاء بمصيرات اخرى
[موسيقى]
الى الولايات المتحده واخر تطورات قضيه
الرئيس ترامب اذ افادت لجنه
المحلفين بان هيئه المحلفين اجلت
التحقيق او القرار بقضيه الرئيس الامريكي
لاسبق ترامب في نيويورك واجلت جلستها
الخاصه بتوجيه الاتهامات لتراب واكدت انها
لن تجتمع اليوم الاربعاء وذلك طبعا لسماع
الادله بخصوص شان قضيه احتمال دفعه ترامب
130 الف دولار للممثله ستورمي دانييلز
والتي كما يعرف بان اسمها الحقيقي ستيفاني
كيلفورد قبل اسبوعين من الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الامريكيه عام 2016 بهدف منعها
من الكشف عن علاقه حميمه جمعتها بتراب
ثلاثيه قاضيه تلقاها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب في الايام الاخيره
فتراب غارق في كومه من المشاكل بعد تلقيه
ثلاثه اخبار سيئه بوقت واحد بشان لوائح
اتهام ومحاكمه جنائيه محتمله في نيويورك
وجورجيا مجله نيوزويك اكدت ان الرئيس
الامريكي السابق يواجه هجوما قضائيا
متصاعدا ما قد يجعل من هذا العام
عامه فالمدعي العام لمقاطعه منعه يستعد
لتوجيه الاتهام للتراب بشان اموال دفعها
لممثله اباحيه عام 2016 مع توقعات باعتقال
ترامب كما رفض قادم تاجيل موعد محاكمه
ثانيه في من اكتوبر طبعا في قضيه احتيال
مدني منفصله رفعتها المدعيه العامه في
نيويورك ضد ترامب وثلاثه من ابناءه اما
شبكه سي ان ان فرجحت توجيه المدعي العامه
لمقاطعه
بولايه جورجيا تهم ابتزاز وتامر لترامب
على خلفيه جهوده لالغاء نتائج الانتخابات
الرئاسيه لعام 2020 في جورجيا تحديدا
ترامب الذي اعلن عن ترشحه الانتخابات
المقبله ينفي ارتكاب اي مخالفات ويصف هذه
الادعاءات بانها جزء من مطارده سياسيه من
قبل طبعا خصومه الديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
للحديث اكثر عن هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
نيويورك مراسل العربيه من امام المحكمه في
نيويورك حصين يعني تاجيل هذا القرار بعد
ما كنا نتوقع ان يحصل اليوم
للنظر طبعا بالملف اكثر ماذا يعني وماذا
تنتظر الهيئه
الى الاسبوع المقبل بالمناسبه حتى لو
اجتمعت اليوم وصوتت على توجيه الاتهام ما
كان
سياتي هذا الاسبوع الى هنا بل كان سيتم
التواصل بين مكتب المدعي العام وبين فريق
ترامب في
رتبوا اجراءات مجيئه الى نيويورك لتسليم
نفسه ولكن حتى الان لا نعرف بما هي
الاسباب لكن
لو سمحت هنا يعني الواضح ايضا تغيير لهجه
الرئيس السابق من حشت ومن يعني تصعيد بانه
سيتم اعتقاله الى لهجه عاديه او معتدله هل
لان هناك اخبار بانه لن يتم يعني توقيف
مثلا
على موقع تواصل اجتماعي
الخاصه الى نقطه مهمه قال بان المدعي
العام لديه مشكله مع اعضاء الهيئه بعد
شهاده المحامي روبرت كوستيريو الاثنين
الماضي والذي يقال بانه قدم ادله تبرئ
ترامبو وهو شكك
بمصداقيه مايكل كهن محامي ترامب السابق
لربما هذا يريح ترامب ربما بالفعل لدى
ترامب معلومات تريح بان هناك مشكله بين
الهيئه وبين المدعي العام كما اشار الى
ذلك هو نفسه لهذا السبب ربما خفف من حده
كلامه واليوم لاحظنا هنا لا موجودون كما
تفضلت موجودون امام المحكمه يعني
الاجراءات الامنيه ما زالت موجوده لحضور
الاعلامي ما زال موجودا ولكن لم نرى
انصارا لترامب مثل ما راينا البارحه عندما
كان من المتوقع ان يتم توجيه الات اليوم
الاوضاع اهدى من البارحه بكثير رغم ان كما
قلت الاجراءات الامنيه الاحترازيه موجوده
هناك حواجز حديديه وضعتها الشرطه الشرطه
موجوده بكثافه اضافه الى وسائل الاعلام
الامريكيه كما قلنا ولكن الموضوع
كله الان يبدو انه تاجل الى الاسبوع
المقبل لان هذه الهيئه تجتمع كل اثنين
واربعاء وخميس بعد الظهر ليس من المعروف
اذا كانت ستجتمع غدا وحتى لو اجتمعت غدا
يقول البعض بانه من المستبعد ان تصوت على
توجيه الاتهام لدينار ترامب خلال نهايه
هذا الاسبوع بل سيتم ذلك الاسبوع المقبل
شكرا لك حسين الطوب مراسل العربيه حدثنا
من نيويورك
[موسيقى]
معقوله ليالي شهر رمضان الكريم بتشهد
اروقه الحرم المكي وساحاته غدا توافد
اعداد كبيره من الحشود البشريه المتوجهين
لاداء العمره والزياره وصلاه التراويح وسط
توقعات باكثر من خمسه ملايين معتمر حتى
نهايه شهر رمضان وتاتي عوده الاعداد
المليونيه لقاصدي بيت الله الحرام خلال
شهر رمضان لما قبل جائحه كورونا في حين
سيبدا تطبيق عمليه دخول المعتمرين الى صحن
الطواف بعد التاكد من الحصول على تصريح
العمره عبر منصه نسك التابعه لوزاره الحج
والعمره من جانبها استعدت رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين لاستقبال ضيوف الرحمن خلال موسم
رمضان بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه وفق
منظومه تشغيليه كامله
بدورها كشفت الهيئه الملكيه لمكه المكرمه
والمشاعر المقدسه عن تخصيص 400 حافله لنقل
المعتمرين والزوار بشكل مجاني ملايين
الركاب من المتوقع ان تنقلهم الحافلات
المخصصه عبر 480 وثمانيه وثلاثين محطه
موزعه في انحاء واحياء مكه مع توقعات بان
اعداد الركاب اليوميه ستتجاوز المئتين
وثلاثين الف راكب ارقام الحافلات والركاب
في رمضان لهذا العام تعد اكثر بخمسه اضعاف
من العام الماضي حيث كانت هذه الحافلات
وكان عددها 80 حافله فقط
مزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من مكه
المكرمه سلطان السلمي مراسل العربيه سلطان
يعني عشيه بدء شهر رمضان المبارك كيف هي
التحضيرات والصوره من مكه المكرمه
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه المشاهدين قناه
العربيه بالفعل خلال الايام الماضيه او
اخر الايام المتعلقه بشهر شعبان شاهد
الحرم المكي اقبال كبير وكثيف من قبل
المعتمرين والمصلين داخل الحرم المكي لذلك
اليوم نشاهد في ليله رمضان نتحدث على
اعداد كبيره من المعتمرين والمصلين قصدوا
المسجد الحرام لاداء العمره وصداء صلاه
العشاء والتراويح نشاهد الان امتلاء
بالكامل لصحن المطاف وكذلك الدور الارضي
وكذلك الدور الاول نتحدثنا عن مئه وسبعه
الاف طائفي يستوعبها صحن المطاف والادوار
الخاصه بالمطاف ايضا كذلك نتحدث عن عمليات
تنظيميه كبيره استعدت لها رئاسه شورى
الحراميه وكذلك كافه القطاعات الامنيه
والخدميه العامله في موسم العمره هذا
العام هنا في الحرم المكي للتعامل مع
اعداد مليونيه
دخول المعتمرين من خارج مدينه مكه لتسهيل
عمليات وصولهم في مده زمنيه لا تتجاوز 16
دقيقه بين محطات النقل والحرم المكي كذلك
نشاهد انتشار امني ملفت وكبير على مداخل
الحرم المكي وداخل الحرم المكي لاداء كافه
الخدمات المتعلقه بحمايه وتسهيل وتنظيم
للمعتمرين هذا العام ايضا نتحدث عن اكثر
من 8000 ساعه تطوع سوف يتم عملها هناك
اكثر من 12 الف موظف من قبل رئاسه شؤون
الحرمين كل هذه الارقام وهذه المرتكزات
وهذه المحاور للتعامل مع الاعداد المتوقعه
هذا العام نعم شكرا لك سلطان سلمي مراسل
العربيه حدثنا من مكه المكرمه شكرا على
هذه المعطيات والارقام
ختام التاسع مشاهدينا مع العالم
قذائف اليورانيوم البريطانيه تعيد مخاوف
اندلاع صراع نوويا انطلاقا من اوكرانيا
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه دول العالم
لاعتقال بوتين وتقديمه للمحاكمه اذا زار
دولهم
شبحوا الخروج من افغانستان يعود للواجهه
بريطانيا تحقق مع جيشها وامريكا تراجع
اسباب الانسحاب
بكامل طاقته للسعابيه الحرم المكيه يستعد
لاستقبال اكثر من خمسه ملايين معتمر خلال
شهر رمضان المبارك
مشاهدينا الى هنا اتي الى ختام التاسعه
قبل ان انتقل الى 360 رمضان مبارك لكل
مشاهدي العربيه والان الى الزميله ميسون
مؤيد ميسون مساء الخير وماذا لديك مساء
الخير ليان وطبعا رمضان كريم عليك وعلى
الجميع ايضا نحن سنتحدث عن هذا التصعيد
الحاصل بين الغرب وروسيا بخصوص موضوع
اليورينيوم المستنفذ الذي اليوم تصدر
الاخبار ايضا لدينا موضوع محاكمه ترامبو
الجدل القائم حولها ايضا الموضوع الاهم
يعني الان في الساعه الاخيره موضوع
الفيدرالي ورفع الفائده ومحاوله منهم لكبت
التضخم هذه ابرز العناوين ولكن ايضا لدينا
العديد من الاخبار متابعينا
[موسيقى]